you've seen them zipping through the
streets blocking the sidewalks dhoklas
electric scooters have appeared
virtually overnight in dozens of cities
so far this year millions of rides were
taken on little machines just like this
and their operators have raised billions
and investments so if you haven't yet
chances are you're going to see stuff
like this pretty soon we see the
scooters navigating through pedestrians
we see them being left anywhere and this
creates you know problems for a number
of people problems indeed if people on
Dhokla scooters or bikes
keep on using the sidewalks it's going
to get crowded
the purpose of the sidewalk has changed
considerably over the last hundred years
when cities first started building
sidewalks the reason for them was to
accommodate pedestrians on the street
but this was not the only use of
sidewalks there were a number of other
social uses a lot of that happens before
the automobile this street scene is San
Francisco in 1906 notice the man holding
a baby just walking straight through
traffic nobody seems too concerned they
are quite relaxed about it and they also
know how to navigate the street but
eventually cars got bigger and faster
traffic had to separate we start seeing
with the proliferation of the cars many
many cities start widening their streets
then of course this happens at the
expense of the sidewalk because a lot of
times the buildings were pretty much set
so you know a sidewalk that might have
been 12 15 feet becomes 6 8 feet which
is pretty unfair for pedestrians because
there's a lot more happening on
sidewalks than walking
there's the frontage zone in cities a
business might put a cafe or signs there
then there's the furniture zone full of
street lights newspaper racks benches
and stuff like that because sidewalks
have frontage and furniture zones
pedestrians have a smaller space to
travel than it might seem some
vigilantes have taken the issue into
their own hands and many cities have
used pilot programs to really get the
scooters under control but these pilots
are likely to extend after all cities
need alternative modes of transportation
first it takes vehicles off the street
because people who might be using ride
Hale or a taxi user another personal
vehicle might instead opt for this other
solution so if a person takes a subway
or a bus to a certain station or stop
they still live a mile away from that
station they have to figure out how to
get there even in cities with
exceptional public transportation many
residents have to travel a last mile
if dhoklas vehicles are deployed in more
areas like this residents could make
better use of public transportation and
not just rely on cars because what many
people will do is say I don't have a
last mile option that works for me so
I'm just gonna drive the whole way the
cash influx for scooter share is really
a bent investors hope that a scooters
can catch through demand in underserved
transportation deserts without adding
congestion and the scooters might pull
that off one survey found robust support
for a scooters as a substitute for short
driving trips but the scooters won't
work if their riders have to compete for
space with pedestrians or cars we're
reaching a point in cities across
America where it's time to get people
out of their cars and allow people more
modes smaller transportation bikes
segways and yes scooters
they only work when cities make space
for them planners can do this by
designing Complete Streets Complete
Streets is a new term that entered the
lexicon of transportation planning
relatively recently basically is
inspired by earlier streets where you
used to have all these different social
uses of streets and sidewalks not only
streets for cars or even sidewalks for
pedestrians Complete Streets start by
reducing the amount of space given to
cars then the city can build protected
bus bulbs wider sidewalks street-level
plazas and buffered bike lanes
scooters will be a more realistic last
mile option when cities built networks
of complete streets so worry not dear
pedestrians even if the scooters are
here to stay
cities are drafting standards for this
brave new world of alternative
transportation and with any luck the
love for scooters just might push cities
to build safer more accommodating
streets hey thank you so much for
watching and a big thank you to the
University of California who hit the
streets to help us film this episode you
can check out their video on the
environmental concerns of shopping right
here again thanks for watching and I
hope to see you soon
[Music]